how to do it better with GT how to tie  the perfect tie the right way one hang  the tie over your neck you'll want the  fat side about twice as long as the  narrow end to take the fat side and loop  it over the narrow side three do it  again for loop the fat end behind the  new not at your neck then take the tip  and slide it through the hole you've  created at the neck slide it in  attaboy and who said this is hard five  pull the fat end to tighten the tie but  leave a little slack 6 to add a dimple  put your index finger just under the  loosely tighten up 7 tighten the ties  you usually do not too tight and good  and that's it that's all you need to  watch about tying a tie for the rest of  your life tip jars over there